warum baust du das Schild ab ich brauche
eins dann craftet ihr eins war doch
nicht mal Sachen bei mir wenn du was
brauchst
nur finden das sind keine Namensschilder
das ist einfach Schilder
[Musik]
ja trotzdem gleich so aufs Maul dicker
[Gelächter]
Leute was ist der perfekt
gemacht um dich irgendwie um die weh zu
tun
du spinnst
ich kotzt privat hör doch mal auf mich
zu schlagen das ist doch total unnötig
deine ganze Gewalt immer
genau deine ganzen Scheiß anderen Dinger
das ist doch witzig das ist ein bisschen
dreht ich habe dir Treppe gebaut mir
bitte ist total schlecht ich sitze und
muss was kotzen
ja digga noch ein Herz dann lass mich
doch auch noch in Ruhe schlag mich doch
jetzt nicht weiß ich checke es nicht ne
du kannst mich immer Pranken ne Diggi
ich egal nächsten Stream wirst du es
sehen
[Musik]
warum konnte ich denn so springen
wie schön das alles noch da ist ach du
heilige Jesus Maria gar keinen Bock
gehabt das jetzt mir neu zu machen ne
ich will das noch einmal sehen bei dir
aber dann will ich deinen Stream gucken
dabei stell dich mal vor mich Sandy
noch nicht springen okay noch nicht
springen erst wenn ich sage okay ich
habe dir das jetzt gegeben und jetzt
spring mal
[Musik]
ja 40 Liegestütze
ja geht so
nee dicker warte ich komme auch mit
meinem Pferd jetzt machen Digger wo ist
denn mein Pferd Luca
[Musik]
hast du mein Pferd getötet
die hässlichen Fackeln
nein nein nein Mama es bringt doch gar
nichts
20 Sekunden später
[Musik]
gar kein Respekt
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das ist einfach so zehn Fackeln die
fehlen wie kann man deswegen so
ausreichen
[Musik]
zurück
die denkt es ist Nacht die wollen
schlafen was hast du getan
steckte diesen neuen Modus sowas von
deinen Arschloch rein ich habe mein Bild
[Musik]
oh mein Gott der macht alles kaputt
nice so jetzt wollte ich auf jeden Fall
mal kurz das hier auffüllen damit das
hier ein bisschen schöner aussieht und
das Haus Herborn Handy wollen wir das
Bauen
[Musik]
welches
hast du gefunden
scheiße
ja ich habe das Bett
wir machen jetzt rechenquiz ich stell
dir so Sachen und du stellst mir auch
Fragen dreimal sieben
21 richtig
8 * 92
[Musik]
gesagt hey ich habe doch 72 gesagt die
Idioten schreibt doch jeder im Chat
gesagt ich schwöre auf meine Mutter ich
habe 72 gesagt
ich habe 72 gesagt mir egal was ihr sagt
mit 42 ich schwöre auf meine Mutter ich
habe 72 gesagt
ja ist mir scheißegal lügen
sag mir nie noch einmal was wegen Schule
[Musik]
wie machen wir das denn jetzt mit diesem
Google
was denn
hatte ja ich hatte kurz gerade ein
Elektroschocker
wenn die wollen wir einfach so ein Wort
gibt's dann Leute gibt's eine Website wo
man sich random in den Wort anzeigen
lassen kann und das bauen wir dann
einfach jetzt noch in einer halben
Stunde
Fragen stimmt sag mir ein Nomen
Himmel ja dicker er sagt mir das Dümmste
was hätte passieren können wie soll man
den Himmel bauen wir machen es normal
für mich ein anderes
Buch okay wir haben Buch und
[Musik]
okay wir haben Buch und Sonne ich bau
die Sonne okay ich baue ein Buch und du
brauchst jetzt eine Sonne oder wie nur
wenige Minuten später also ich bin
fertig ich auch
[Musik]
zeig mal deine Sonne
komm willst du mein Buch sehen
dicker wirklich dümmste dass du ihm
Deutschland
das ist sehr langweilig Luca ich bin
jetzt offne Ciao Bruder ich gehe auch
auf Leute schaut das Handy dann erstmal
nicht wenn ich an der Stelle auch ne
Handy
[Musik]